hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one of the general points that comes up
at a number of places in seneca's
Treatise on the shortness of life is not
to be or to allow oneself to become
preoccupied and this is a translation
for the Latin term ocupatus meaning you
know focusing one's attention one's mine
on something in particular probably a
whole bunch of things and Seneca is not
saying well don't ever Focus your mind
on anything but the preoccupied
spend their life the time that they
actually have the most precious
commodity
on things that don't really Merit that
level of attention and they do it in
ways that are bad for them and why
because they consume the life that they
have which could be a vast span of years
and Seneca says more than ample for
anything that they would want
they turn their life into one that
becomes All Too Short
and Seneca you know points this out in
chapter 10 he says I could come with
come up with many arguments to
demonstrate the life of the preoccupied
is very short but instead I'm going to
you know make a frontal attack not with
little pinpricks not with a bunch of
little
you know arguments here and there but he
says nevertheless for the preoccupied to
be censured for their distinctive
failing they have to be taught a lesson
not simply given up for a loss so that
tells you a little bit about what's
going on in the book it's not just for
philosophers it's for everybody it's
it's for anybody who might be getting
whether they realize it or not sucked in
to a preoccupied life
and it's not the very first place that
he talks about the preoccupied we're
going to come back to those in just a
bit but I think it could be good to
focus on chapter 12 where he raises the
topic and he says do you maybe want to
know who I'd term the preoccupied and he
says you know we've got people that we
can clearly say are okupate right who
are preoccupied with things for example
lawyers driven out of the Law Court only
when the Watchdogs are finally let in
for the night people who are like
putting in you know countless hours in
the law court or those patrons you see
crushed with either impressive display
in their own crowd of admirers or more
contemptuously in someone else's crowd
or those clients whose duties summon
them from their own houses in order to
dash them answer the doors of others or
those the Prater spear keeps busy for
disreputable gain which is today someday
bound to Fester so we got a couple
different kinds of people so the client
Patron in relationship which is very
important in Ancient Rome you can think
of it as like having people who are your
entourage people who are your Hangers On
that's a busy life right and that's kind
of a problem he goes on
and he says
it's not just those people even the
leisure
of some people is preoccupied and so he
gives you a few examples that you know
apply to ancient Rome but I think we
could think about in our own time in
their country Retreat around their couch
in the midst of their Solitude even
though they've withdrawn from everybody
they are troubling company for
themselves they can't be on their own
and alone and be successful in that
they're always looking for distractions
he says this is not being leisurely but
a life and he uses this a couple
different points a life of idol
preoccupation right Idol in the sense
that you're you're not being compelled
to do anything but you can't enjoy that
time that you actually have to yourself
and you preoccupy yourself with all
sorts of other things and you've seen
this before people who literally can't
sit still and just be alone with their
own thought thoughts they always have to
be on their phone you know checking uh
one app or another or they have to be
twiddling their thumbs and looking at
them and doing things with their body or
they have to be looking around at other
people and wondering what they're doing
right starting conversations with random
strangers so he gives a whole bunch of
examples of these
do you say that a person is at leisure
who arranges with meticulous deep
attention to detail his Corinthian
bronzes right so this could be anything
that we collect right it could be
statistics it could be sports
memorabilia it could be magic the
Gathering cards anything that a person
can obsess about what about the person
who sits at the wrestling ring
enthusiastically watching boys brawling
who separates the troops of his own
well-oiled wrestlers into pairs of the
same age and skin color who maintains a
stable of the freshest athletes this is
like somebody who actually owns a
wrestling group they're obsessed with it
right they're constantly moving people
around nothing is ever just good enough
for them what about people who spend
many hours at the barber well any
overnight growth is trimmed away solemn
consultation has taken over every
separate hair disheveled locks or
rearranged your thinning hair is combed
forward and he he says you can tell that
they're preoccupied because they get
ticked off really easily if the barber
is a little bit too careless right
um he goes on about this what about
people who are absorbed and composing
listening to and learning songs we might
ask about this in our own day where we
have an entire vast music industry that
caters to us we can listen to almost
anything that we want to
and some people just obsess about this
sort of thing right and he goes on to
say what about Banquets and not class
their Banquets among leisurely pastimes
because I see how anxiously they arrange
the plates how they gather up the tunics
of their servants at table how they're
on tenterhooks to see how the boar turns
out from the the cook and he goes on and
on and on people are throwing uh parties
or you know feasts they're not at
leisure either they're preoccupied right
so a lot of people as he's going to say
in section 13 he says it would be a long
business to run through the individual
cases of people who've spent their whole
lives playing checkers or playing ball
basking their bodies in the sun people
whose Pleasures put them to considerable
work are not at leisure
he gives a very funny example that I
think perhaps some people can relate to
not just an academic Pursuits but in all
sorts of other things where people
quibble about stuff and have to show how
smart they are
he says nobody will doubt that those who
devote their their time to useless
literary questions and we've got a lot
of these in Rome are busily engaged in
doing nothing what would be examples of
these worrying about how many rowers
Ulysses had whether the iliator Odyssey
was written first whether they belong to
the same author Seneca says I mean these
are interesting questions but are they
really worth wasting your time on maybe
not so because they're not helping you
to live a better life coming back to his
first mention of the preoccupied early
on in chapter three he tells us that
there's all sorts of uh vices that we
are going to be subjecting ourselves to
and this is you know going to be a
considerable problem he's already
mentioned a number of these back in
chapter two vices are sailing and
surrounding us on all sides they don't
allow us to rise again and lift our eyes
to the clear discernment of Truth they
keep on dragging us back in even having
wealth can be a great burden to us right
and so he says that
um you know think about people who
pretend that they're going to live
forever how much time do they lose to
groundless anguish foolish pleasure
greedy desire the charms of society how
little is left to you from your story of
time you're throwing it away you're
throwing away this most precious
commodity on all of these other stuff
and he's going to go on and say you know
one of the problems with the preoccupied
is that they actually can't appreciate
and spend their time doing things that
are really worth doing so this is in
chapter seven he says
everyone agrees no area of activity can
be successfully pursued by someone who
is preoccupied and so a little bit more
literally no area of activity can be
pursued well can be executed well the
Latin here is
can be executed can be seen through Bene
means well so you can you know he's
going to use the example of rhetoric
right you can study rhetoric you can go
online and watch all sorts of YouTube
videos about Aristotle's rhetoric and
CIS Rose Redick and seneca's own
rhetoric and you know think that you're
quite well versed in this sort of thing
but you're just kind of pissing away
your time you're frittering it away
you're not actually buckling down and
learning it and you could be preoccupied
even in learning you could be like Oh
I'm learning the rhetoric I'm going to
be such a great lawyer and you're
filling your head with all these
Daydreams not pay attention or whatever
you're studying he also talks about all
the other liberal arts as well the
things that we call the humanities right
and we can say this even about technical
skills like coding you know you're
probably I mean you can learn coding
while doing other stuff but if you're
distracting yourself you're probably not
going to learn it that well you're not
going to learn it as a human being does
not just as a bunch of stimulus response
things or a checklist but an activity
that we can participate in so that's an
important consideration he also talks
about uh times right a lot of
preoccupied people are ignoring the
present that they're supposed to be you
know enjoying and focusing too much on
the future in ways that are kind of
unproductive so he will say
for example this is in uh chapter nine
can there be anything sillier than the
view of these people who boast of their
foresight they're too busily preoccupied
with efforts to live better live better
here in the future they plan out their
lives at the expense of life itself they
form their purposes with a distant
future in mind the greatest waste of
life he says lies in postpone it robs us
of each day in turn snatches away the
present by promising the future that's
that's what we see lots and lots of
people do
unfortunately not living for the time
that they actually do have to to live a
bit he goes on as well and talks about
people who are
there we go
people who are praying for a long life
old men begging their prayers for an
additional few years they pretend
they're younger than they really are
they flatter themselves by this and they
deceive themselves as if they deceive
fate but they they cry out that they've
been fools because they haven't really
lived they'll live in Leisure if they
only Escape their illness
but they've already thrown away much of
their life there's also a discussion in
chapter 16 as well which is quite
important and this is in talking about
um postponement right so when we are
looking forward to something not so much
in the distant future but in the near
future we can easily get ourselves
preoccupied with that he talks about
people who complain that the hours pass
slowly until the appointed hour for
dinner arrives when their usual
preoccupations fail them and they're
left with nothing to do they don't know
how to apply their free time or how to
drag it out so they move on to some
other preoccupation and find the
intervening time burdensome right any
postponement they look of something they
look forward to is long to them but the
time of actual enjoyment is short and
fleeting made shorter by their own fault
they desert one place pleasure for
another and cannot persist steadily in
any one desire so this is a big problem
right and what ends up happening is they
they render themselves unable to enjoy
or appreciate the present that they
actually are in and could be in a
non-preoccupied a leisured way enjoying
right and spending wisely so this is a
significant uh issue he also talks about
some of these people being focused on
the present but being present or being
focused on the presence in a way that
doesn't actually help them so he says
um
you know the present time is very brief
indeed so brief that to some people it
seems to be non-existent it's always
hurrying on the preoccupied are
concerned with the present alone and it
is so fleeting it can't be grasped even
that little amount is stolen away from
them because they're pulled in so many
different directions sometimes they'll
do things like worry about are they
really appreciating this are they making
important memories and this leads us to
another very interesting thing that
Seneca points out
they like to make memories they like to
you know think that they're setting up a
store for themselves but they're really
not because preoccupied people as
opposed to those who are better oriented
in this way can't really go back into
the vast resource of our past this is in
the course of seneca's discussion of the
three times past present and future he
says that it takes a tranquil and
untroubled mind to roam freely over all
the parts of life preoccupied Minds
cannot turn around and look backward
their life disappears into an abyss just
as it does no good to pour any amount of
liquid into a vessel if there's nothing
at the bottom to receive and keep it it
makes no difference how much time we're
given if there's nowhere for it to
settle and it's allowed to pass through
the cracks and holes in the mind you
know somebody who does in fact make
memories and revisits them has this
entire wonderful past we can even use
other people's past he talks about the
philosophers offering us entire ages
that's not available for the preoccupied
person even if they have a library with
everybody's books or you know courses
online teaching them about everybody who
who they think is important if they
can't actually
dwell in it it doesn't do them any good
and preoccupation prevents dwelling you
could say
there is a one other point that we'll
we'll close on you know Seneca is
addressing this to a friend of his uh
paulinos and he tells him that you know
you're really allowing yourself to be
preoccupied with all this work that you
do for The Granary and making sure that
people are you know fed and you know the
grain is coming in and he he tells us
that the plight of all preoccupied
people is wretched but most ratchet is
the plight of those who labor under
preoccupations
that are not even their own
whose sleep schedule is regulated by
someone else's who walk at someone
else's Pace who are under instructions
in that freest of activities loving and
hating
so you know when you see somebody as he
says taking up the robe in office or a
name well known in public don't envy him
these people are taking on
responsibilities that cause them to be
preoccupied he has examples of these
earlier in there which include you know
some pretty famous important people and
so you know what is the the ultimate
goal here Seneca wants us to understand
what's so problematic about allowing
ourselves to become preoccupied with
things that in the long run don't really
matter or they don't matter to the
degree that we give them our time our
Attention our very life instead we want
to be carving out for ourselves some
scope of leisure not preoccupation